那你这话说的，
我要是你老公，
我要是你婆婆的话，
我听你说这话我也不乐意了，
就好像你老公和你婆婆这些年付出的劳动，
付出的经营，
在你看来的话，
那玩意儿就是蛋，
鸡是你的，
就从一开始这个买卖能做起来，
是你出的这只鸡，
而他们得到了那些都是蛋，
主要功劳在你，
你看你说话这个逻辑给人的感觉不就这样的吗？
但说吧，
我老公结婚已经有快10年了，
感觉有点沟通不太了，
就是爱生气，
不知道为啥他就生气了，
有点拿不准，
你不用管他的话，
他过两天他就好了，
他可能觉得没啥了，
可能习惯了，
但是我就有点受不了，
我就老怀疑，
我说是不是我哪里做的不太好，
或者说是哪里有问题啊，
然后跟他沟通，
他就说啊，
没事啊，
我也没生气，
必许是这种状态，
刚开始那几年也吵过，
因为我的性格就是那可能有啥事儿说清楚了，
别人老过夜的是是冷暴力躲避他就不沟通那种，
过了几年之后，
我觉得心里累的很，
他那个点的那个视频，
我就想就这么过也行，
我就图他钱就算了，
但是我感觉这两天我就又有点儿心里又有点受不了，
他一年挣多少钱呀，
他有正式的工作，
工作的话一年到手有一个，
但是我们现在有一个小生意，
这个钱是直接到我手里面，
大概是50多，
到我手里面找生意。
主要是靠谁打理呀，
主要是靠我婆婆跟我们在重庆的区县，
我生活这个地方跟我那个生意那个地方不是一个区，
需要我婆婆过去帮我销售，
我们老公负责特殊了，
维户老就在家带两个小朋友，
等于是说婆婆和你老公主要负责去挣这个钱，
但这个钱呢，
是落你手里了，
一年有个50来万，
然后你老公还有一份正经的工作，
一年还能挣十来万，
是这意思不对，
你看可以怎么暴力呀，
我该关心你，
我关心你，
你回应是你的事儿，
你不回应，
反正我做到位了呀，
是不是啊，
我也没挑，
我就一直看过你那个视频，
我就觉得也可以，
你就像你说的，
我总里要图你点啥我那我就图我手里这点钱就行了，
这个不是一点钱啊，
姐妹，
你知道你60万的家庭收入味着什么，
意味着咱普通上班族10个男人才能挣出来这60万的年收入，
但是他那个手里面的钱，
他是要支付工人工资的，
就相当于每个月的话要支付大概1万多的工资，
他到手里大也没有多少钱了，
但是你这一年50万的收入是在你手里啊，
对，
我不纠结钱的事，
我不知道到底是我的问题没做好，
还就是他让人家老上去的原因，
还是说他这个人就这样，
我不管怎么做都做不到他身上，
我现在已经不纠结。
再说是他到底是因为合适才选择到我，
还是说是感情也好，
我都不注意这些问题。
那天我看到一个剪辑的一个片段，
这个剪辑的片段是一个两个老外，
他俩具体经历了什么事儿我不知道，
但是那个故事的情节应该是这个男的在外头有人了，
老婆就问他，
就在外头找这个人吧，
他也不比我年轻，
他也不比我漂亮，
他也不比我瘦，
就你为啥找他，
咱俩不能好好过？
这男的就说，
因为他更柔和，
他更安静，
他愿意听我说话，
他从来不会对我大喊大叫，
也不会骂我闭嘴，
也不会骂我是蠢货，
他不会让我觉得我是这个世界上唯一那个让她不幸福的人。
大概就是这段对话，
我想表达什么意思呢？
如果说婆婆和你老公把钱大头都交到你的手里了，
其实表示人家是想好好跟你过日子的，
咱这么说话没毛病啊，
但是我就是不知道为啥他有的时候要甩脸子，
那就是他自己可能本身是一个心情不容易好的人呗，
那就跟咱没关系了，
如果咱做到了不骂他，
不贬低他，
不主动挑起这个争端，
如果咱做到了柔和，
做到了倾听，
愿意听他诉苦，
愿意听他讲他工作的不容易，
愿意听他他的这个风光的时刻。
如果这些东西都。
做到了，
但他还是不快乐的话，
那就是他自己是一个不容易快乐的人，
但是我不能因为他不快乐，
所以我就要去跟着他不快乐，
我自己一年手上五六十万，
我宝宝健健康康的，
我一年多快乐，
他要是甩脸色的话，
我就带着宝宝出去玩儿去，
我就带着宝宝去游乐场去，
我就带着宝宝游泳去，
我是这样调节过我自己，
但是我发现我就很容易被他的情绪影响，
就是我看见他回来之后不开心，
马上我的心情就跟着一下就下来了，
那这种情况你试一下，
你不用去问他你怎么了，
你怎么不开心了，
不问，
就是一杯热茶，
一杯饮料，
切个水果，
切个果盘，
就是我，
我自己很难排解我自己，
我就觉得我已经就是很小心翼翼的看着他的脸色在说话，
那些就是不知道什么原因，
他是那种性格很孤僻的那种，
他不爱说话，
不像你说的，
他回来当上有个什么事啊，
他要说一下呀，
他都不说，
他下班回家之后也没有多的话，
就是他心情好的话就跟孩子逗一逗，
他心情不好的话，
反正就是往那一坐，
就玩他的手机，
一直到睡觉，
我们两个也说不上两句话，
我主动去跟他说两句话的话，
他还有那种爱答不理的那种感觉，
我就很容易胡思乱想，
但是。
我知道他外面没有那些不三不四的，
我感觉我也好像也没有走到他心里那种感觉，
那你现在想要问我的问题是啥呀？
是和我的问题做的不是让他满意吗？
还是说他是不是那种性格的人，
他一直都这样吗？
还是生完孩子才这样吗？
还是突然有一天这样的呢？
之前我感觉还是挺好的，
但是因为碰到事情沟通之后，
我跟他沟通，
他不沟通，
吵架吵得多了，
我就觉得就这样吧，
反正沟通了也没有起效果，
就吵架，
这种有了问题我们俩都不沟通，
他爱两高六，
等几天好了之后，
他就又像原来一样了，
我也不去细想这些问题，
按照他的心情，
他高兴了他就开心，
他不高兴了的话就回家，
就拉脸。
你有听过那个撒娇宝典的课吗？
在你的那个推荐下，
我去关注过，
我也去试过，
但是他就感觉有点油盐不进的那种感觉，
你听过几遍那个课之前，
刚开始你推荐那段时间，
因为我也很迷茫，
我就长期把他的那个切派拿出来，
长期在前让你，
你为了改善夫妻关系，
你连花了几百块钱去听课，
你都没有付出，
那你的付出就没有付出到点子上，
只果你没有花钱，
是不是我没有花钱，
我就光听他那个其实听，
那我问你就是为了你能够缓解夫妻关系，
你所做的努力，
连花几百块钱都不愿意，
那你做了哪些努力呢？
比如说他不喜欢吃外卖的。
东西我就每天变着花的，
给他弄了好吃的，
你没有努力到点儿上点儿是什么？
我跟你说，
男人这辈子就图三件事儿，
一被看见，
二被认可，
三被尊重，
就图三件事儿，
但是我感觉我也挺尊定他，
我也没有否定他呀，
你有没有跟你老公说过这样的话类似啊，
打个比方，
老公我是真没有想到我能找到像你这么有能力的男人，
你看你自己有正经的工作，
你看我连个正经的工作都没有，
但是你从来都不嫌弃我，
而且你除了自己有正经的工作，
你一年还那么辛苦，
跟妈你们两个啊，
还能为家里创造这么好的经济条件，
为孩子创造这么好的未来，
我觉得真的是有福气，
我真的很感谢你，
我也感谢我妈妈这些年的付出，
我也这样表达过，
他就说啊，
你少说那些外酸话，
我对老公说是没有你的话。
我说我和孩子过不上这么好的生活，
我说妈也特别辛苦，
我说我也特别知道妈特别不容易。
那我再问你，
这些年婆婆那么不容易，
你给婆婆买过一个金镯子吗？
你给婆婆买过一个金项链吗？
婆婆所有的镯、
金镯子、
项链，
包括家都是我给她买的，
爸婆婆婆婆婆家的房贷、
水电费、
生活开支都是我出的好，
那你给你老公买过什么东西呢？
老公所有的东西都是我买，
因为他钱，
说白了，
钱都是在我这儿，
你想要啥，
想买啥我都是买。
回来的他想换车我们就换车，
他想换房我们就去看房，
包括他那些什么玩游戏啊，
包括他回家就玩游戏那些我从来没有管过，
你想玩就玩，
那如果说你什么都做到位了，
那他就这性格呗，
那你就没有问题呗，
那你就全都做到位了呗，
不知道我怎么该怎么去调节一下我这种心情，
我就感觉他一就是这样，
一就就那样的，
我都不清楚了，
他到底是想过还是不想过，
那你有没有想过他可能是抑郁了，
有没有说能够关心一下他的心理健康啊，
跟他提这方面的话，
他就不想说，
他说他身体不舒服，
我就给他买那些，
比如说黄芪精呀，
什么红参液那些给他，
他也喝，
我已天问他有没有效果，
他说好像没啥效果，
我说不行，
咱就去看看中医啊，
你如果耽误了试看那个试干的，
你觉得辛苦的话，
我说你不想干那个领导那个，
就是小组长那个图了，
你就别干，
我说都可以的，
我说你干什么我都支持你，
但是他好像嗯，
也没有表现出很那什么的呀，
那他除了对你这么冷漠之外，
他对别人呢，
他有没有对谁特别客气啊，
特别温柔啊，
特别耐心的，
他对外人都挺客气的，
但是他从来没有一个朋友，
也没有任何异性，
没有朋友也没有异识，
他到点就上班，
到点就上班，
他甚至连自己就是那种加班的工作，
他都不愿意去。
我他就说每天想着就是我把我手上那个活儿干完，
就赶紧回家，
回家他也不能说是跟我聊天啊，
反正回家就是你们爱干啥干啥，
我就玩我的手机游戏，
然后吃饭，
如果说他确实就是不爱了，
你能接受吗？
我能接受，
那他就是不爱了，
那怎么样才能让我们之间的那个就是生活氛围不要那么低压呢？
那他都经不爱我了，
为啥还舔他呢，
他都已经不爱我了，
他只要钱交给我，
他的任务就完成了，
我俩就可以相安无事了呀，
我俩就平平安安的过呀，
他不爱我，
那我也就不期待，
说我生病了，
我头疼了，
我发烧了，
他能来摸摸我，
抱抱我，
给我掖掖被子，
我不期待啊，
因为他人家不爱我呀，
我没有这个期待呀，
那咱俩不就是平平安安的过了，
你把挣的钱交给我了，
时不时的就那种拉脸子，
整个家庭啊，
就感觉孩子都在看他脸色这种，
那是的因果，
就孩子从小看到一个拉着脸色的爸爸，
孩子不愿意跟他讲心事，
孩子不愿意跟他分享快乐，
那是他的因果，
他今天种的因，
将来结的果，
就是孩子跟他不亲了，
这是他的因果呀，
你就管他就好了，
不是这个意思，
姐妹，
我刚你说的所有的建义，
你都说你做到了，
如果说有东西你都已经做到了，
杀人不过头点地，
你还能怎么样呢？
如果我刚刚跟你讲的。
不管是撒娇课也好，
反复听也好，
反复用也好，
还是给她买礼物也好，
给婆婆买礼物也好，
夸婆婆也好，
就是所有的东西你都做到了，
那还能怎样呢？
就只能自己调节自己的情绪，
你说我不知道他不爱我，
或者说是怎么样，
因为我感觉我这段年解不需要谈爱不爱了，
你再去听一个课程，
被讨厌的勇气不讨厌，
坦率的说候啊，
被讨厌的勇气这个书误可能60%的人看不懂，
买了也白扯，
买了也白搭，
他看不懂你就去听，
去听各种博主对这本书的解读，
各种博主对这本书的分析，
就是听就行。
真的，
我没骗大家，
我直播间有没有买了这个书看不懂的，
扣60/100的人是看不懂的，
没有耐心看下去的，
但你可能听别人看懂了的人解读这个书，
对你会有豁然开朗的这个作用，
就算你们买的时候看不懂，
也不要觉得哈哪个主播骗了你似的，
因为看不懂是我们还没有到那个修炼到那个功力，
所以看不懂。
一旦有一天你看懂了这本书的话，
你感觉你自己就飞升上仙了，
飞升上神了，
你跟原来的你不在一个层次，
不在一个思想的维度，
最讨厌的勇气看完这本书，
我感觉我就超脱了，
谁也别来搞我的心态，
谁也别想搞我的心态，
没人能搞得了我的心态，
其实就是我们这个状态，
就是在大家看来都挺好。
的，
但是这个日子我过，
我知道好像很累那种感觉，
我跟我婆婆我们关系都挺好的，
我生孩子那个月我出钱，
我婆婆去帮我撑场面去干的，
不是说我占着他们来，
他们家就有这个买卖，
是我生孩子那个月我们才拿结婚收的那个钱，
我也没有他们家彩礼那钱去做的这个买卖，
当时我跟我老公是一个朋友单位上班的，
当时家里面商量就是我来带孩子，
我婆婆去做这个买卖，
造成了我全职在家的这个状态，
不是说我是图他们家啥东西的，
也是从零开始的，
我们你看你这话说的，
我要是你老公，
我要是你婆婆的话，
我听你说这话我也不乐意了，
就好像你老公和你婆婆这些年付出的劳动，
付出的经营，
在你看来的话，
那玩意儿就是蛋，
鸡是你的，
就从一开始这个买卖能做起来是你出的这只鸡，
而他们得到了那些都是蛋，
主要功劳在你，
你看你说话这个逻辑给人的感觉不就是这样的吗？
我还心是这样子，
是傻的，
但是我感觉我憋屈的另一个点就是你这么想就不对啊，
你这么想就是不讲道理啊，
你这么想就是把自己的功劳放大若干倍，
把别人的功劳缩小若干倍的想法呀，
你这么想就有问题啊，
对，
所以说我从来也没敢说过，
你看你这话说的，
所以说还是我的问题是来自富。
错，
内心不平和就是造成了我现在这种局望，
客观的讲，
你确实是你前面出了本钱，
本钱是结婚收来的这些礼金，
但是咱不能无条件的放大自己的功劳，
真正要去挣钱，
一年能挣50万的，
那不是还婆婆没日没夜的在那守才能挣来这50万吗？
对以所以说我很感谢她所说，
婆婆那些生活开支，
我全部没有怨意，
全部就是给我们家开支。
哎呦喂，
我跟你说，
我现在能理解你婆婆和你老公就你说话，
这话头的话让人听了真的不舒服，
那钱是人家婆婆没日没夜挣回来的，
好像这钱就交到你手里就是你的似的，
好像你给婆婆买点吃的，
买点喝的，
买点这些东西不是应该的吗？
你也不交到你手里，
人家想买什么买不起，
那所以是我呢，
我是怎么回事呢？
你就是真的有点儿钱交到你手上，
你以为这钱就是你的了，
你要搞清楚钱交你手上是人家可能婆婆比较照顾你的情绪，
觉得你带孩子不容易，
把钱交到你手上，
我问你，
她要是钱不交到你手上，
你能跟他打官司吗？
是啊，
怎么这钱交到你手上，
就好像你是大家长，
你我就给他买这个我都不在乎，
她吃点这个我都不在乎，
她生活上的开销全是他挣的，
大姐，
那我现在就应该就是说喊我婆婆回来帮我带孩子，
我现在去那边去守着个生意一起做，
这样子的话，
我就稍微可能要好点，
可以。
你你直接雇个人啊，
如果你能让婆婆轻轻松松的，
你雇个人看孩子，
你自己去挣钱去，
这个时候你挣的钱，
你说我给婆婆买金镯子啊，
我给婆婆，
我不在乎婆婆吃，
不在乎婆婆穿，
那是你大方，
你因为那钱是你挣的，
你当初你是拿着婆婆挣的钱装大方，
还是嘴上装大方，
对呀，
我们现在是雇了人的，
只需要一个人在那儿看着，
这样子的话，
我就可以让我婆婆回来帮我看孩子，
我过去看着就行了，
就可以了，
也行啊，
你婆婆给你看孩子，
你也得给婆婆发点钱呀，
对，
我们都是这样子的好不好，
那就这样啊，
好，
再见啊，
我这人吧，
有的时候你这话你要不说那么透的话又说不明白，
你话说透了吧，
其实是给我自己招祸，
你知道吧，
你们可能不理解龙飞这个点，
你不要以为说来连麦了，
来找我了，
来咨询了，
来花了300块钱了，
跟我就一定是一条心了，
跟我就一定是朋友关系了，
未必啊，
因为你讲话讲的太直了呀，
伤自尊了呀，
伤到人家了呀，
可能人家心里还挺恨你的，
刚刚有很多朋友都在说龙飞你为什么不找男人的问题，
你为什么对女人那么苛刻，
其实我一般情况下上来是先吵男人的问题呢，
是人家说了，
男的没有外遇啊，
男的没有红颜知己啊，
男的没有别的异性啊，
人家上来就说明白了呀，
男的他也没发现呀，
那我我这逻辑，
我肯定是上来先吵男人的问题，
但是没有啊。
至今没找到啊，
记得点赞关注哦。